Let's get back to hearing from you via discord
at David Pakman dotcom slash discord.
Let's go next to Adam from Los Angeles, California.
Adam, you're on the air.
Hey, David.
So I actually wanted to ask about DACA and
the Dreamers.
Obviously, it's been a roller coaster for
them.
And, you know, now with a slim majority in
the House and Senate, how likely do you think
it'll be for not only people who are in DACA,
but people who maybe narrowly do not qualify
to get some relief?
I'm confident that the current DACA participants,
current participant doesn't seem like the
right word, those who currently qualify for
DACA status.
I think that in relatively short order, they
are going to be taken care of now in terms
of expanding DACA to include more people.
I think there's more of a question mark around
that, and it's really too early for me to
have a strong sense of of how likely it is
that DACA will be expanded.
Totally, yeah, because I know even as recently
as twenty nineteen, the DREAM Act obviously
got blocked by Mitch McConnell in the Senate.
Yeah.
And didn't even be it wasn't even brought
to a vote.
But I know the bill itself has always had
bipartisan support, so hopefully something
can happen there.
You know, the disgusting reality is there
are despite bipartisan support, there are
likely Republicans who may want to stand in
the way merely to deny Joe Biden an accomplishment
on this.
And that's really sad because we're talking
about people's lives being at stake here.
Yeah, livelihood's maybe better said no.
I think it's disgusting.
And I guess the hope is that, you know, something
can get done about that.
You know, would they need any bipartisan support
even to pass it to?
You know, that's a really interesting question.
It's without really reading more about it.
I don't know how much can be done by simple
majority, how much can be done by executive
order and how much would need 60, 60 votes.
And so I don't have an answer on that at this
immediate moment.
I think it's something I'm going to have to
read up on.
Absolutely.
Well, thank you so much for your time, David.
My pleasure.
Great to great to speak with you.